stuff going on my question like did you
guys do the system link thing with the
TVs or we just kind of just playing the
campaign it was it was just normal
screen like all of this stuff I was
complete
out of my depth with I was only like
kind of into video games I played them
at friends houses but I didn't really
understand it yet I still I I didn't
understand like what they were really
like I understood how movies were made I
understood that how from a young age
that like oh people edit and like
they're actors that go film but like
video games for whatever reason I was
like this is like a portal into some
other dimensions I really had no it was
like magic to me and then I think 2005
2006 with the when I got the 360 and it
we had like online for the first time
and I was I was playing
splits or couch Co-op or like
competitive multiplayer with like people
in Egypt and London and I was like these
are real people that broke me again yes
that's like just all this stuff where
it's like I can't yeah that's real
that's